mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
ja was bedeutet wissen heimat und ist es
mehr ein ort oder eingeführt und wie
entstand überhaupt unsere heimat die
moderne schweiz so wie wir sie heute
kennen ja auch bei dieser frage kommt
das st galler dorf chance und stehen
ein listiger streich sorgte offenbar
ganz genau vor 175 jahren dafür dass die
moderne eidgenossenschaft überhaupt
gegründet werden konnte dieser
geschichte gehen danach und wir zeigen
ihnen auch mehr vom shanice
[Musik]
dann ist feiert sich also dieser tage
und dafür wurde eigens ein theaterstück
geschrieben die renommierte regisseurin
barbara schlumpf hat den
geschichtsträchtigen streich ins heute
übersetzt
man will geübt sein
regisseurin badora schlumpf bespricht
sich mit dem laien ensemble vor den
grünen
25 darsteller innen der comedia der
barcodes nach rekonstruieren ein stück
schweizer heimat nur einen steinwurf
entfernt vom ort wo am 2 mai 1847
historisches geschehen war diese
kirchturmuhr soll damals eine zentrale
rolle gespielt haben
[Musik]
manipulation passiert
was damals vorgefallen sein soll ist in
schweizer geschichtsbüchern kaum zu
finden dennis aber prägt es bis zum
heutigen tag
herkunft die rund 470 zwar letzte wort
hat jetzt aber
riskant erinnerung das ist wie die
gesellschaft wo der werdegang hat das
ist nicht nur historisch sondern aus
lettland zurück zu den tatsachen so viel
ist belegt alles beginnt hier auf dem
rathausplatz von janis die landsgemeinde
wählt und der ausgang der wahlen ist
eine sensation die liberalen siegen
völlig unerwartet mit haushoher mehrheit
es folgt eine politische und
militärische kaskade ersten st gallen
dann im ganzen land sie führt zum
sonderbundskrieg der letzten schlacht
auf schweizer bürger die liberalen
siegen und der weg zur modernen schweiz
ist frei
als folge wird 1848 der bundesstaat
gegründet die schweizer hält ihre erste
verfassung und wird damit zum
einzigartigen demokratischen staat
mitten im monarchistischen europa
doch wie es dazu kam darum ranken sich
legenden die wale janis mit der alles
begann sollen manipuliert gewesen sein
die liberalen hätten die kirchturmuhr in
der nacht vor der wahl um eine stunde
vorgestellt ihre politischen gegner die
konservativen verpassten dadurch die
abstimmung
wirklich
ein freilichtspiel über ausgeführte und
ausgetrickst die wahlmänner die den gang
der heimatlichen geschichte verändert
wären da nicht die frauen an der
historischen china waren fehlten sie
gänzlich ihre stimmen zählte nicht im
stück übernehmen sie nun tragende rollen
regisseurin barbara schlumpf und autorin
rebecca thieschnieder lassen die
ereignisse durch frauen erzählen und
zeitkritisch kommentieren aber
[Musik]
überhaupt dass man irgendwie erhalt
dikmen h mit mit dem stück hinter rainer
frey historische faktor der geschichte
gibt einen zähler und normalbürger für
das drama über laser oder es geht ihr
wunderbar ausstellung begleitend zu der
produktion gemacht war ich aber weil das
theater machen versprach sie da
irgendwie etwas erhalten dahinter sehen
ein mehrwert und
[Musik]
mit mit den quellen es gibt ein wirklich
meine momente
die frau vor
hier
macht nicht nur spaß
[Applaus]
das ist ja wirklich habe gar nicht alle
frauen können mit entscheiden in der
version von mir
mit dem stück entscheidet er
dahin die jetzt im dax ebenfalls neu und
auch einige asiatische
es ist nicht
laufen sondern
[Musik]
sie machen sie genau und darum wird die
china kirchturmuhr im stück von einer
frau vor gedreht
wie auch immer die geschichte gewesen
sein mag diese fehlende stunde die
damals hier vor dem rathaus in china's
vor exakt 175 jahren eine kaskade
politischer umwälzungen in gang gesetzt
haben soll diese schicksalshafte stunde
beschäftigt die sängerinnen und sänger
immer noch
[Musik]
ja
am dorfbach wahrscheinlich ist richtige
motivation kollegen alois brunner du
bist ja darauf wie oft
kunstunterrichts es zweimal im jahr also
ich ganz glück hat es mit brettern oder
wohnt das heißt das ist doch jetzt
verbindlich nur zum ort seines
44 lokalpatriot bin ich find's super was
diedorf bestellten menge interessante
geschichte so lode historisch steige das
was die truppe jetzt gemacht wie viel
zutrauen durch hütte da nach wunsch es
ist durchaus durch lee die karten sind
für einen großversuch wie hat überall so
siebenjährige sasha
auf die
erinnerungsreise dahin der aufgefrischte
hinter den bäumen gebüsch und es ist
wahrscheinlich gar kritik sie habe das
bild ist sehr spät nachts überhaupt
schlaf pro tag und dann darauf jetzt
springe so der sprung ist freiheit von
kinski und vor der schule so in neue
tage ja das ist schließlich wachse sei
dort so viel ahrensburg sich meine zwei
brüder und zwar nach der damaligen acht
bleu die dekra
sieht canale den bach ins kam mit
stirnlampen gemein ist ungewisser
kracher wieder neu ist dass wir jetzt
einmal machen ja doch ließ statt für für
freie gegenteil zu sein
[Musik]
hmm
was uns menschen heimat bedeutet diese
frage bekommt eine ganz andere wucht
wenn wir an die geflüchteten aus der
ukraine denken ja aber was ist uns
heimat wirklich ein gefühl ein
sehnsuchtsort ein konzept
[Musik]
darüber haben wir nachgedacht unter
anderem mit donna leon die bestseller
autorin lebt seit einigen jahren in der
schweiz und inzwischen ist sie sogar
schweizer staatsbürgerin
sie ist klar zu besuch in zürich um ihr
neues buch vorzustellen star autorin
donna leon im september wird sie 80 mit
dieser großen lebenserfahrung gibt es
für sie so etwas wie heimat
ich kann keinen ort mehr heimat nennen
weil die definition davon so schwammig
ist
heimat wo wir die meiste zeit gelebt
haben oder ist heimat dort wo wir am
glücklichsten in unserem leben waren
gebt mir die definition und ich nenne
euch die stadt geht mir die definition
und ich nenne euch den ort
die us-amerikanerin stammt aus new
jersey ging als studentin nach italien
1980 ließ sie sich in venedig nieder die
erste wahl heimat hier entstanden alle
ihre bestseller die krimis und den
venezianischen ermittler guido brunetti
der neueste bereits 31 fall erscheint
demnächst
warum ist sie hier weggezogen venedig
und leon eigentlich die perfekte
symbiose
[Musik]
ja das war auch so als ich aber nach
venedig zog es war so um 1980 herum da
konnte ich noch nicht vorausahnen dass
es einmal zu einem disneyland werden
würde und daher unbewohnbar
15 jahre schon hat sie darum eine zweite
wahlheimat mischte im abgelegenen
münstertal in graubünden exakt in der
mitte zwischen dem standort ihres
zurcher verlages diogenes und venedig
hier kann sie entspannen und arbeiten
seit eineinhalb jahren ist leon zudem
schweizer bürgerin und entscheidet an
der urne mit über die zukunft in ihrer
wahlheimat
gut verortet und doch immer auch
unterwegs in der welt offen für
einflüsse von außen
so definierte auch der
kulturwissenschaftler walter leimgruber
von der universität basel für sich
persönlich heimat spitz hatte ganz weit
meine heimat begann unterwegs
neu gegend erkennen und eigentlich gibt
es kein ort und ich nicht das gefühl
haben dass sie dazugehören oder einfach
mit daheim bin
ursprünglich war heimat ein räumlicher
begriff gekoppelt an das heimatlied das
wohnhaus im ländlichen umfeld das mit
gewissen rechten verbunden war über
lange zeit war es klar dass terror von
traditionalisten volkstümlichen und
national konservativen kreisen
heute kann damit auch das teilen von
gewissen werten gemeint sein eine
sehnsucht nach gerüchen aus der kindheit
oder vertrauten kulinarischen genüssen
das zelebrieren von nationalen
identifikations und projektionsfigur
und dann ist heimat auch immer eine
frage der perspektive ist man ein heim
oder zugewandert
denkt man an heimat haben die einen
verlustängste andrea erkennen in einer
neuen heimat auch neue chancen
die könnte demnach ein moderner
heimatbegriff aussehen einer der nicht
nur die vergangenheit glorifiziert
man muss sich aber bewusst sie das
teilnetz dort liegt wo mehr als das
vergangenheit räume sondern heimat ist
eigentlich bis aktiv heimat ist wohl
mehr hersteller mehr sind selber
verantwortlich dass mehreren heimat hand
das heißt ministerium schaffe und das
ist eigentlich nicht anders als ein
gesellschaftlicher prozess womit uns
darüber reden wie wir es eigentlich wie
wenn das umfeld gestaltet
wenn man das könne demokratischen
prozess
eigentlich automatisch heimat und
heimatfestes stabil sondern heimat ist
ein prozess wo man sich touren wieder
neu verortet in der sich verändernde
umwelt mehr als nur eine heimat zu haben
ist heute realität das buch zwei
heimisch beschreibt dies anschaulichen
zwölf patres von menschen die in die
schweiz gekommen sind um zu bleiben oder
die als sehr groß hier aufgewachsen sind
insgesamt betrifft das gut ein drittel
der schweizer bevölkerung
was nicht heißt dass heimat für alle das
gleiche bedeutet
heimat ist für mich ein ort wo ich mich
wohl fühle wo ich auch
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten habe wo ich
gewissermaßen
gerechtigkeit erfahren und mich auch für
die teilhabe am gesellschaftlichen
geschehen engagieren kann basel ist
heimat schweiz ist heimat geworden haben
[Musik]
veränderte konflikt mit dem vorhalt der
herkunft von ihnen ältere und zu ich bin
gut in
das ist für mich kein ort sondern die
art wie man sich vor
auch die art wie man sich verhält wie
man die lehrer erlebt
[Musik]
heimat ist der ort wo die menschen
verwundet
und auch die abertausenden geflüchtet
aus der ukraine konfrontieren uns aufs
neue mit der frage was heimat für einen
wert hat was es bedeutet seine heimat
aufgeben zu müssen sie vielleicht für
immer zu verlieren also das ist schlicht
und einfach zur nächsten katastrophe
materiell viele flüge aus sozial auf
allen ebenen vertrautheit es braucht
also das haben wir eigentlich
wahrscheinlich ein sozialprojekt
verschnitten assoziiert die wirtschaft
bewege gehen sie hartz passe die finden
auch an einem neuen ort der heimat die
wir es nicht schaffen die flüge je nach
dem sogar die alte heimat und sind
glücklich fühlen und heimatlos im
gegensatz dazu konnte sich die wahl
schweizerin donna leon frei entscheiden
ist sie nun für immer angekommen
unsere heimat sollte sich nach der
dauerhaftigkeit des verbleibs richten es
ist der ort an dem du denkst dass du
dort bleiben wirst
und ist das jetzt vielleicht das leben
ist lang und es ist kompliziert
eine erkenntnis heimat hat immer etwas
ambivalentes
ist aber nichts stars und lässt sich
grundsätzlich überall neu erschaffen
[Musik]
ja
da bin ich im kinsky und damit
verschafft sind praxis kann
wirklich sagen ja sozusagen
ich hatte stolz was hat das für dich
bedeutet dass ich habe mich oft dafür
ganz
auf das ist ja wie die ruhe vor dem team
von rico fata sie mit großvater statur
und das abstreifen
und im kleinen dorf und die große stadt
wo ist dann mehr konnte mich also
einsatz der heimat ist wo man sich mit
muss erklären
und mit dem heimatbegriff kann ich sehr
gut leben das heißt es aber dass
konzerne müssen sich stegner oder gibt
es
offiziell ihre normale
mitglied um das lebensgefühl manchmal
viel wohnraum nordmann erwachsen da
verstehe ich als martin ja also ich muss
meine größe 40 also wechsel statt und es
macht noch viel los
jetzt hat jeder nacheinander zusammen
aber keine chance
der schweizer fotografen tim roth geht
es in seiner arbeit immer wieder um
herkunft und heimat und so hat er zum
beispiel seinen kollegen eddie begleitet
und zwar in dessen heimat seneca
ich sehe meine kinder nicht aufwachsen
das tut einem vater wie
das motorrad ich erinnere mich daran wie
hessen spanien gekauft haben ich sagte
wir haben ohne möglich noch platz im
auto für dieses ding und ich sagte wir
müssen das aber mitnehmen
dümmer inschallah heißt das fotoprojekt
von tim roth es zeigt wie er die firma
seinen freund auf der reise von bern
nach dakar begleitet auf dem landweg die
hat die reise schon mehrmals gemacht das
auto immer bis unters dach bepackt
smartphones
geladen
überladen
das hast du mir gegeben geschenkt
eindruck hat wie man
dass gerade sie mit ganz viel morgana
haut dezembermorgen und wir haben fest
vor norwegen und art wieder unterwegs
ist networt beeinflusst und eine
rückkehr
beobachtet
am anfang hatte mir gesagt er werde
fotografieren ich habe gesagt kein
problem und so hatte er es gemacht
erster linie möchten wundert die
distanzen zurückzulegen auf dem landweg
und in der zerfahrenen das macht
drucker ist vor dem verein recht simpel
so geht's einfach
europa das loch aber
mehr als 60 stunden waren die beiden
unterwegs zügig vorbei an spektakulären
kulissen angehalten haben sie jedoch
bloß zum essen und schlafen und tim roth
fotografierte wo es möglich war und
machte zwischendurch videoaufnahmen zur
dokumentation und erinnerung schlimm ist
offensichtlich
polizei
ich habe die schilder nicht sagt er
liegt aber im anschluss an das ist
lächerlich es ist unglaublich er liegt
versteht
[Musik]
mit sehr mühsam ii grenzübergang zum
teil nach grenzach es ist etwas was nach
merzig wird drückt
ausgeliefert zum teil was man für einen
der versucht man hat irgendwie die ganze
palette oder schlussendlich
bestärken
dass david souter wunsch wasser und
straße zu stellen deutlich
weniger und die westsahara
alternativen eingriff straße weiter
werden um so einfach mit dem
motorradfahrer
und es gibt auch stelle auf der route
war das geräusch das mehrheitswahlrecht
musst du für dein land für dich für der
mitte thront vor dem museum so was die
medien
fabritius der blieb stärken sondern
sich mit der aggressivität
hintergangen und irgendwie
mit bewusst wort
für ganz lange
zeit war die hoffnung auf
bessere wirtschaftliche möglichkeiten
wie im
exil alaba und versucht hatte das im
familienheim unterstützen also ist das
ganze ein rohr hat politische tragweite
herz
öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
klar ist es nicht dasselbe in einem
anderen zu leben aber ich fühle mich
eben sowohl in szene und in europa
geht es gut weil ich jeden sicherheit
leben
was mir fehlt ist meine familie
das ist meine mutter
und das ist meine tochter
ich sehe meine kinder nicht aufwärts
aber ich habe keine wahl
man muss arbeiten und meine arbeit habe
ich hier in europa nicht zu hause in
senegal
acht tage und nächte und fünfeinhalb
tausend kilometer später erreichen die
beiden ihr ziehen
es wird wie erwartet von ihm mit mit
sachen und wo es heißt ja die europa
league geschafft haben und ihnen mit
lara hunt der tacho das ist sicher auch
der druck für
mich hat der weiß wie bewusst wurde das
privileg dass sie eine hak ich mache das
ja blog seines lebens abenteuerlust wenn
jährlich bei und für die ard ist
realität
auch wenn ich nicht alles habe was ich
möchte dass ich mir wünsche hindert mich
das nicht daran glücklich zu sein
[Musik]
das liegt
wurz der schlacht haben ja besonders gut
aber mein kind hat die demnach und den
superstar gibt es ein anderes gefühl für
heimat sehen
mobile doch lieber etwas gibt es in der
mobilität
das stoße man nachher
sagen wir noch was machen nichts für uns
schluss machen und gerade jetzt folgt
auf sf1 sternstunde philosophie über
astrologie
[Musik]
natürlich lieben
vielleicht
das ist ein gefühl
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]